the bits of cultural furniture that are
sitting there that we're like oh yeah
that's been there for years oh yeah
what's what could possibly weird about
it you know and then we're gonna lift up
that piece of furniture and look at all
the bug scurry away you know what's your
childhood memories never happened your
brain just made them up Adam ruins
everything started as a web series for
college humor hosts Adam Conover
examines and debunks widely held beliefs
that just so happened to be wrong you
like it so you're putting a ring on it
what if you were wondering why we put
diamond rings on things we like it all
oh god you're gonna tell us the awful
truth about engagement rings aren't you
yeah I am true TV picked up the series
and expanded it to a half-hour show
which is in the middle of its first
season airs on Tuesday nights we sat
down with Conover to discuss the
underlying philosophy of the show and
asked them what it takes to be a good
ruiner
one of your early episodes looks at the
TSA actually the TSA doesn't protect us
from terrorist attacks could you just
ruin the TSA a little bit for now yeah
sure it's that one's kind of low-hanging
fruit I feel like a lot of people
already suspect this but the TSA has
never stopped a terrorist attack or at
least we don't know that they've never
set a terrorist attack because they've
never claimed to have stopped a
terrorist attack the reason for that is
that the TSA security is totally static
right like all they do is screen items
for discrete things and then scan your
body in this specific way right that
it's a you know very easy for a
terrorist if they want you to figure out
like all right what aren't you scanning
for right now and go through and around
us what the TSA actually does is a
concept called security theater which we
learned about from this security writer
Bruce Schneier security theater is the
idea of putting on a big show of
security in order to make people feel
safe you know when the TSA has these
items that are not actually dangerous
but you'll be stopped if you take them
through they post on their Instagram
feed the stuff they confiscate they
posted like a a grenade like a plaque
with a fake grenade on it like a novelty
thing you know
would no-one is mistaking this for a
grenade no one could ever mistake it for
a grenade right but the TSA says novelty
grenades are not permitted you know why
and you know this this weird sense of
you know by taking things away they give
the impression of doing something and as
you mentioned the TSA is kind of
low-hanging fruit it's something that
everyone kind of feels a discomfort with
but you do take on topics that are kind
of cherished beliefs whether it's
engagement rings or fingerprints or cars
have you ever taken on a topic that you
ruined for yourself something that you
thought oh man I really wish this were
true or something there's a few topics
in our sex episode that's coming up in a
couple weeks that were things that I
genuinely didn't know at all that the
writers brought to me I won't spoil what
they are but they're two like very
commonly held beliefs about the human
body that I didn't I wasn't aware that I
was wrong about which was a very
wonderful sensation to have you know to
feel that like holy holy crap myself you
know this feeling we're trying to give
the audience I got to experience in our
hygiene episode we talked about why you
don't really need to shower every day
there's no medical reason to shower
every day a dermatologist will say
actually if you shower every day you can
over dry your skin really you just need
to watch your armpits and crotch but you
know soap companies you know sort of
like advertised and sort of instilled
this this cultural habit of you must
shower every day and if you don't you're
gross I do still shower every day
despite knowing that because I feel
disgusting if I don't shower every day
in the same way that I also bought my
girlfriend a piece of diamond jewelry
after shooting the the diamond
engagement ring section part of the
thesis of the show is that you can't
escape culture you can learn about it
you can criticize it you can try to move
it slowly but at the end of the day you
can't you can't actually opt out of the
culture that you're in I mean it seems
like you know we're in an age where
everything is a Google search away as
far as information goes so all the
information is out there yet these
misconceptions that you're taking down
in the show persist why is that well as
interesting you say Google be well
information is right out there it's
right it's right at their fingertips but
also what you want to believe is right
there you know so it's the classic thing
of someone you know googling autism
vaccines and you know they'll find out
what they're looking for depending on
what they think you know if you google
first engagement ring and people will
watch our show and go google it first
engagement ring and they'll say wait a
second the first engagement ring was
given by like a Bavarian Prince said in
1524 or whatever now that little bit of
story is part of the De Beers
advertising campaign that was like a
thing that they put in newspapers and
magazines and stuff to make it seem like
an older tradition it's not false that
that happened but that was just one
example of a guy who gave a ring one
time and De Beers says that was the
beginning of the trend it wasn't you
know so with that example I mean it
caught on and it spread so quickly and
so easily it almost makes it seem as if
like the culture was hungry for this
symbolic sacrifice that people could
make did sure do you think that's
possible that's that's definitely
possible I think though that the main
thing is that a corporation company like
DeBeers is a social entity that exists
to get money for itself right that's the
purpose of it that's what it'll do I
think that what we need more of in
society is corrective institutions that
try to influence people in the opposite
direction that pull them the other way
and so that's what I hope that the show
is we watch the show you see these
little citations pop up remember in fact
that you're putting out there could you
explain your decision to do that there
are so many people on TV who just tell
you this is the truth right and here I'm
telling you the truth and believe me
right now we're kind of doing the same
thing but but on our show like we could
be wrong about these things you know we
don't have a huge research staff we do
have one but they're not enormous you
know we're a bunch of comedy writers and
you know journalists like like putting
together you know what the truth is to
the best of our knowledge and us showing
our sources is saying here is the
material you can use yourself to
question our show because this is the
work that we did so if we quote a staff
it comes from this w-h-o study and if
you you can say hey actually this study
had a bad sample size or whatever it is
that you might say and I hope that
people do that and if we get any that
are you know credible I would like to if
we get if we're lucky enough to do more
episodes to like do a you know
corrections episode
Adam ruins Adam ruins everything exactly
yeah we've talked about that a couple
times yeah yeah unless you have a habit
of undermining your own beliefs and of
being curious about these things you
won't look into those things more deeply
and part of the thesis of the show and
the mission of the show is to help
instill that habit in people when you're
talking about examining truth claims
your everyone is looking through their
own lens but there doesn't seem to be a
strong like partisan lens or anything
that you're filtering your your show
through you know I have political
beliefs like anybody else but that's not
what the show is about people have told
me like you should do an episode on
Planned Parenthood on the truth about
Planned Parenthood right depending on
what they think the truth about Planned
Parenthood is you know we're not going
to because there's no way for me to do
an episode here's the truth about
Planned Parenthood where every person
the audience won't already know what
they think about that I want to do
stories that are about the things that
we take for granted in our own lives and
never think about you know like the the
bits of cultural furniture that are
sitting there that we're like oh yeah
that's been there for years though yeah
what's weird about it you know and then
we're gonna lift up that piece of
furniture and look at all the bugs
scurry away the underlying mission of
the show is to promote skepticism free
inquiry questioning your own beliefs do
you feel that the culture itself is
moving towards that it's interesting to
me it's it's not so much the culture
changing it's that people always wanted
this stuff if you look at the content
that does well on the internet like the
most viral content you know there's some
categories of it you know BuzzFeed stuff
that's like the relatable content oh
that's so me right but the other there's
another big category of it like here's
something amazing you didn't know that
really hooks into people the other
cultural change is that comedy has been
starting to be taken much more seriously
in recent years you know ever since I
think of it as like post daily show
comedy right where you know that was
really a turning point where people
started to realize that like oh comedy
and satire can have a true cultural
impact and can have something to say
that is serious John Oliver show came
out as we were in production on this
show
and I love that show so much and it
really showed that oh there is an
audience for what we're about to do you
know I also see a comparison between
shows like Penn & Teller's [ __ ] or
Mythbusters yeah are there any other
shows you besides John Oliver that had
an influence on how you're approaching
this and bringing it to television I
used to watch when I was a kid a lot of
PBS and I realized after we started
making this I was like this show is
actually very similar to it's like
Beakman's world or or Bill Nye the
Science Guy for adults in a way it's
very visual and we have these comedy
characters slide in and do their demo of
whatever the topic is you know it's a
great show very fun and educational it's
Adam ruins everything Tuesday nights on
truTV Adam thank you very much for
talking thank you so much for recent TV
exact way